MALE SPEAKER: Nick, Google.
Google, Nick.
I'll do that again.
NICK OFFERMAN: Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for coming by.
NICK OFFERMAN: My pleasure.
Oh Jesus.
MALE SPEAKER: We're up in the
San Francisco office.
NICK OFFERMAN: We're
on the Jumbotron.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
There are folks from other
offices who I think are just
peeking in.
I'd like a higher angle, sir.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So Nick's in town,
in northern California,
just to stop through--
usually you come through to pick
up wood, but this time
you're actually coming through
for kind of dual reasons.
One is for-- you have an
"American Ham" show tonight?
NICK OFFERMAN: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: And then there's
also a premiere of "Somebody
Up There Likes Me"
tomorrow night.
NICK OFFERMAN: Tomorrow
at the Roxy.
MALE SPEAKER: And how many
"American Ham" shows has it
been so far?
NICK OFFERMAN: I think it's
about four dozen.
I got invited last year,
about a year ago to
speak at some colleges.
And I thought, by god, I have
some things I'd like to say to
the young people.
And so I wrote this show,
and it was really fun.
And then more colleges
invited me.
And then the show ended up
being kind of humorous.
So then we turned it
into a real show.
And now I'm just playing at
legit theaters like the
Masonic Center this evening.
And it's also been super fun
because my wife has a new band
called Nancy and Beth, and
they're about as entertaining
as anything I've ever seen.
And so they've been
opening for me.
And it's quite a package.
MALE SPEAKER: Is it something
that you had always wanted to
do as far as kind of a one man--
because you're not a
stand-up comedian as such.
NICK OFFERMAN: No.
I never--
I'm a trained theater actor.
I never dreamed that I would
perform as myself.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that tough?
Is it hard to play yourself?
NICK OFFERMAN: Well, no.
Because as my dad always
said, I have a
good line of bullshit.
My grandpa was the mayor of my
small town in Illinois, and my
dad is also kind of a
former politician.
So I wasn't too freaked out.
I think if somebody said, I need
you to go do an hour of
stand-up, that would
make me scared.
Because I don't think
I'm particularly
much of a joke writer.
I put together a show that's 10
tips for a prosperous life,
and then I laced it with things
that make people laugh.
And it seems to be
working out.
But I always say that I'm a
humorist and not a stand-up.
MALE SPEAKER: And then over
the course of the year and
plus that you've been doing
this, do you make adjustments
to the show?
Is it kind of originally what
it was and it still is?
NICK OFFERMAN: The skeleton
remains the same, the 10 tips,
and If I do a tight version
of the show,
it's about 90 minutes.
But usually, it comes in over
two hours, because I am known
to run off at the mouth
on something
that strikes my fancy.
So every show has about 30 or 40
minutes of unique material
that I pull straight
out of my ass.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, it's nice
that it's your show, so it's
your prerogative.
NICK OFFERMAN: It is.
It's really fun.
And everyone seems to have a
pretty good time, unless
they're faking it.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, as far as the
fact that you've been an
actor originally coming from a
theater background, now you're
a writer, and now a producer
with "Somebody Up There Likes
Me." How did that come to be?
NICK OFFERMAN: I guess
organically.
I've always, I guess, written
things that I--
little stupid funny things.
There's a great group from the
Bay Area, and I think they
were prevalent in the '70s,
maybe into the '80s, called
the Firesign Theater.
And when I was in college, they
were like a radio play
group, but sort of a pot smoking
version of a radio
play group.
And they were super,
super funny.
They had five or six albums
that were a big deal.
And I was very inspired
by them.
So when I was in college, I
wrote some stuff kind of
emulating that medium.
And I've always been a big
fan of Garrison Keillor.
But even on my show, I am by
far the one who's always
pitching a lot of--
for better or worse, I'm always
pitching stuff for
everybody to say, which I think
some people like and
some people might
find irksome.
But so then eventually my boss
asked me to write an episode,
which was really fun.
And this friend of mine that
I've worked on a bunch of
films with asked me to produce
this film that we're opening
at the Roxy tomorrow night,
"Somebody Up There Likes Me."
And it's all just
very organic.
And then this year, my boss
also asked me to direct an
episode of "Parks and Rec."
And they don't come about
because they're things
that I aspire to do.
They just come about because
we love collaborating as a
group, and there's a--
my boss decided he thought it
would be funny to see if I
could write one, or my
friend wanted me to
produce this movie.
It wasn't that I had any kind
of resume as a producer.
He just thought that my energy
and work ethic would help.
And it's a small crew.
It's 20, 24 people.
It's a very low budget movie.
And so I was a very
creative producer.
We had a second producer named
Hans Graffunder who worked on
"The Sopranos," and now he
produces for Terrence Malick,
who's an up-and-coming filmmaker
you'll be hearing
more about.
And he's the dad.
He ran the office.
He did all the paperwork he
knew where to find all the
money we needed.
And I helped the wardrobe ladies
carry clothes from
their car to the set.
I ran the set and he
ran the office.
So I kind of learned how I am
a producer as I did it.
MALE SPEAKER: And having those
dual roles, so not just being
a producer, but actually
being a lead in it, is
it difficult to--
or how is that different than
just having one role, on, say
"Parks," or in theater?
NICK OFFERMAN: Well, the
downside of directing or
producing is that they want you
to pay attention to the
whole goddamn thing, which takes
a lot more energy than
just working as an actor.
I don't think I would
want to--
I don't know if I would want
to producer or direct
something that I had a
really huge role in.
Even though I have a leading
role, I don't have long
monologues or any days that are
particularly strenuous,
beyond standing in the right
place and making funny faces.
So I think if somebody wanted
me to direct myself playing
Hamlet, I'd probably demur, or
at least get a co-director,
get my wife signed up.
MALE SPEAKER: As far as roles
that you really think you'd
like to tackle in the future,
are there ones-- whether
they're theater, whether
film-- that you'd
like to take on?
NICK OFFERMAN: Yeah, sure.
I mean, I don't really fit the
mold it to play someone like
Hamlet or some of the greater
leading man roles.
Wouldn't mind taking a crack
at Rozencrantz or
Guildenstern.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: I'm keen to do
something with the role of
Theodore Roosevelt.
I think that would
be a lot of fun.
My friend Conan O'Brien really
wants to produce something in
the realm of Teddy Roosevelt,
but we're talking about--
we can't figure out what to do,
because we can't really do
something serious and have
his and my name on it.
It'd be like, a dead-serious
biopic brought to you by the
funniest tall redhead
ever created.
MALE SPEAKER: Well isn't John
Stewart actually now directing
something serious?
Maybe he's leading the charge.
NICK OFFERMAN: Maybe.
Maybe we'll--
who knows.
I mean, it's something
we talk about a lot.
I don't know if it'll
come to pass.
There's a lot of roles
like that.
There's this great character,
Ernest Shackleton, who Kenneth
Branagh beat me to.
But maybe that'll fade from
memory soon enough that I can
take him on.
He led an incredible South Pole
expedition in the very
early 20th century or
late 19th century.
There's a lot of roles
like that.
I'm not particularly
ambitious.
I like seeing what comes
down the pike.
MALE SPEAKER: It sounds like
"Somebody Up There Likes Me"
is something that booked
because you were asked.
And actually, the genesis for
it started out here, right,
just kind of outside of
this building, almost.
NICK OFFERMAN: Well, yeah.
The last time actually I was the
lead in the film was this
movie called "Treasure Island."
It's set in 1943, and
it's based when it was
a naval base out
there on Treasure Island.
And the movie looks like it was
made in the early '40s.
We shot it actually on a period
camera called a Mitchell.
The filmmaker was a very
wonderfully weird old timey
meticulous filmmaker.
And it's a delightfully
difficult film.
It's like if David Lynch
made a film in 1941.
There's a lot of kickass
sex in the movie.
But we should we shot a scene
right out by the fire
department down there
on the water.
There's like a piece
of decrepit pier.
We shoot a pivotal scene with
the Bay Bridge in the
background.
And we got them to turn their
lights on in the middle of the
scene, which was very
exciting for us.
It was one of my most Michael
Bay moments I've had to date.
MALE SPEAKER: And then that led
to a friendship that then
evolved into him
asking you to--
NICK OFFERMAN: Yeah, Bob
Byington, this filmmaker who
wrote and directed "Somebody
Up There Likes Me" was the
script girl on "Treasure
Island," and
that's where we met.
And we liked the cut of
one another's jib.
His writing is really smart and
funny, and he has a great
dry sense of humor.
So he kind of kept me around.
Every couple years, I would fly
myself to Austin and do a
couple scenes in his movies.
He finally wrote me a nice big
part, and then asked me to
produce it.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's
coming out--
well, it's already come out,
but it's being premiered
tomorrow in San Francisco.
NICK OFFERMAN: Yeah.
We're having a big event.
I'm going to be at all the
screenings at the Roxy tomorrow.
And I believe I'm giving away an
Offerman Woodshop mustache
comb at each of three Q&As.
MALE SPEAKER: And speaking of
woodworking, as long as you
went there, oftentimes I think
you come up, you said, to
northern California to pillage
our wood and bring it down to
turn into whatever catches
your fancy.
As you've evolved and have your
own woodworking shop,
where does chainsaw sculpture
fall in the pantheon?
Is that one you think
you might tackle?
NICK OFFERMAN: No.
Never.
I have a few very large
chainsaws that I love to use.
But I don't--
there's actually a few small
tools known as power carvers
that are like a little right
angle grinder, but they have a
little circular chainsaw
head on them.
And carving with a machine--
I'm not much of a carver
to begin with.
But carving with a machine
doesn't appeal to me.
If I was ever going to try
carving, I would do--
I mean, what little carving I've
done, I do with gouges,
and I do it by hand.
MALE SPEAKER: And do you have
something that you eventually
are going to be working towards,
your Rachmaninoff
three that your big--
NICK OFFERMAN: Woodworking is
something I love doing and I
hope to continue to improve at
for the rest of my life.
I don't have--
I suppose a pipe dream would
be to build maybe a wooden
sailboat before I'm done,
but nothing too big.
I don't want to ruin
my marriage.
But right now, we're getting
ready to build some ukuleles
in the shop.
And that's--
we love the ukulele, but it's
also with an eye towards
trying some acoustic guitars.
If we get any good at that,
maybe we'll try some other
instruments.
I have the luxury of--
because I have a nice waitress
job during the daytime, I
don't have to make kitchens for
people with my shop, and I
can kind of pick and choose
what I want to make.
So I want to try some stringed
instruments.
I always hope to build
more boats.
Those are incredibly
satisfying.
But who knows.
Maybe a grand piano one day.
We'll see.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, if folks
want to start lining up in
front of the mic to ask any
questions, please do.
But I wanted to talk a little
bit about your writing with
"Parks and Rec" and
how that evolved.
Was it something that you have
been asking for, you wanted to
kind of try it out?
Or did it just come to be?
NICK OFFERMAN: I let my
boss know early on.
I went in and said, I just want
to let you know that if
you ever have anything
more for me to do--
because I come from this theater
company in Chicago
where I generally would build
the set, and I would make the
props, with help.
It's always a wonderful
collaboration, but I was the
technical director
of the company.
I had all the tools.
I was a makeup artist.
I was a fight choreographer.
And so when I get with a group
and we love making some sort
of entertainment together, and
they just want me to show up
and crack wise and then go back
to my trailer, it's not
how I'm trained.
I'm like, well, I'm just
sitting in my trailer.
Is there something else
I could be doing?
Can I sew buttons
on something?
So I told my boss early on
that, like, if there's
anything else I could do--
and we love making each
other giggle.
So a couple summers ago,
during the off
time, we had lunch.
And he asked me if I wanted
to write an episode, and I
totally started crying in the
middle of this restaurant,
where I was like, yes, that
would be fine with me.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: And I said of
course, I would love to.
But why--
like, you can get
the greatest--
people really love our
show and hold it
at a very high level.
You can get the greatest talent
to write an episode?
Why would you ask this guy?
And he said, because I don't
want to get somebody who wrote
a really funny movie.
I love making the
show with us.
And it sort of came from
the same vibe of just
collaborating as a group and
enjoying this lucky time where
we're allowed the freedom to
make the show how we want to.
MALE SPEAKER: And making the
show by us, is that something
that's very much, during the
filming, there's a lot of
collaboration there in the way
which you actually shoot
scenes and try out dialogue?
How does that work?
NICK OFFERMAN: Well,
we're so spoiled.
Because our writer's room is so
brilliant that none of us--
we could be really pretty lousy
actors and still come
out smelling like a
rose, because the
writing is just so good.
They have that ability--
we get asked a lot of questions
in the sort of
bailiwick of, do you guys--
do you write everything
yourselves?
Or like, did you make
up everything
about Ron Swanson yourself?
Because it seems so much--
it seems to fit you
so naturally.
And that's just what great
writers do, is they pick out
parts of your personality and
then writ it large as a sort
of cartoon.
And they do it so well that
people are like, oh, Nick
obviously must have made
that up, because no one
could think of that.
But in truth, they did
think of all of it.
And so it is very
collaborative.
We get on set, and we have
these beautiful scripts.
But then we're all goofballs
with our own skill set.
And so Pratt is my favorite.
He is such an amazing
combination of a boyish sort
of clumsy child,
combined with--
don't let him fool you.
He is a fucking genius, when it
comes to coming out of left
field with improvisation,
nobody--
I mean, Amy is just
an amazing--
like, Amy is a corporation
all of her own.
She's like a comedy factory.
But Pratt's sitting over there
just waiting for the camera to
throw to him, and he floors
us with this cleverness so
frequently.
But everybody does.
I mean, everybody has
their own flavor.
And so that just-- when you
start with a great script and
then have all of these home run
hitters sort of throwing
in their additional ingredients,
it just makes it
for an incredibly fun
collaboration.
MALE SPEAKER: And it sounds like
everyone trusts everyone
to step it up.
And because it's so fun, just
dive in with the best of what
they've got.
NICK OFFERMAN: It is, yeah.
It's a very safe environment.
Greg Daniels sort of learned
this system on the American
"Office," RIP.
My life was completely
changed by that show.
And he created this paradigm
wherein when we started our
show on the very first
day, he said, this is
very important, everybody.
If you ever feel like you want
to do anything or say
anything, you can.
You have permission.
We're no longer shooting
on film.
We can shoot all day.
We don't have to cut
the cameras.
So if you feel like getting up
and going over there and
making a sandwich, you can, as
long as it's natural and it
feels like it's part
of the scene.
And so the first couple episodes
then, of course, have
just hours of masturbation,
where I was like, well, Greg
said it would be cool if
I go over here and
take my pants off.
And then the edits started to
come in, and we're shooting
hours and hours of footage for
a 21 and 1/2 minute episode.
And so we quickly learned,
like, OK, maybe that's a
little indulgent.
MALE SPEAKER: How to make
friends with the editors.
NICK OFFERMAN: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Welcome.
NICK OFFERMAN: Hello.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
You mentioned the writers kind
of pick up on aspects of your
personality to build the
Ron Swanson character.
And you yourself just a moment
ago said you were really
interested in Teddy Roosevelt
and Ernest Shackleton
quote-unquote rugged
individualists.
And I think Ron Swanson
falls into kind of a
subcategory of that.
And I'm wondering what draws
you to those characters?
NICK OFFERMAN: Gosh,
I don't know.
I grew up in a farm family
in Illinois, and they're
certainly rugged
individualists.
I grew up in the '70s, and
we were not doing great.
And so there was a lot of
pulling ourselves up by our
own bootstraps and flying by
the seat of our pants.
And then we get into a more
sort of middle class
existence, and then sort of got
swept up with the rest of
a lot of our society into an
incredibly comfortable world.
And I think that I just
personally long for--
I would rather not be inside
in the air conditioning.
I would much rather be in a
canoe on a river, even if
there are mosquitoes, or even
if it is a little scary.
That just feels more alive.
And in the career that my tool
set led me on, I never
imagined that I would
become a performer.
Going into the arts was unheard
of in my little farm
town, but inexplicably, I
managed to do it anyway.
And that was necessitated
being in an urban area.
I went into theater, so you
had to be someplace where
there's an audience.
And so as I've lived in cities,
I always yearned for
the sort of canoe of my youth.
And I think that's a
lot of what led me
to maintain my woodshop.
It makes me feel like I can
still hold my head up around
the farmers in my family
who are so badass.
I mean, when people ask me,
like, if I'm manly or what do
I think about manliness,
I say, I'm
the sissy in my family.
I'm the one that went and
took ballet in college.
Go talk to my uncles, who are
still welding their own corn
wagons out of scraps
around the shop.
And so I think in the world of
what I do for a living, I like
to choose things--
I would much rather go shoot
something where I'm playing a
lumberjack and I'm getting
to spend a few
months out in the woods.
Even though I'm going to work,
it's much more delicious to me
than working in a sound stage.
And you know, the place
that our country is in
right now, I often--
whenever I get riled up,
certainly during election
years, and I want to do
something or I want to make a
difference, I always have to
say, well, the thing I can do
I think the most effectively is
reach the audience that I
already have in place.
And so I try to choose subject
matters and characters and
stories that I think can have
a positive influence.
In my "American Ham" show, I
talk a lot about encouraging
people to be more of a
rugged individualist.
Even if you live in the city,
you can now become a
blacksmith on your back porch.
Or you can set up a knitting
business and
sell things on Etsy.
And I feel like that is the kind
of thing that's going to
help us keep from being squashed
by China, if we're
going to succeed
in doing that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NICK OFFERMAN: You bet.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I love the show.
One of my favorite parts
of "Parks and Rec"
is the Jerry jokes.
And I was wondering how Jim
O'Heir is in real life.
NICK OFFERMAN: I don't
talk about Jerry.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: No, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious.
Are those jokes written in
the script, or does it
just kind of happen?
NICK OFFERMAN: No, actually.
We secretly hate him.
No, Jim O'Heir is the sweetest,
the greatest guy.
He's in his early 50s
or his late 40s.
And he's worked steadily as
just a character actor.
And for a guy like me or Jim
who's been in town, been in
the business for so long, to
land a spot on a show like
this, you could literally punch
me in the balls every
scene, and I'd be like,
I don't care.
I'm so happy that I'm
on a show this good.
You can have my testicles.
It's worth it.
And Jim talks a lot about
that, that he's
like, are you kidding?
I've got such a great part
on this funny show.
But we do have to be careful,
the rest of us, not to let it
bleed over.
Because it's so delicious, the
whole shitting on Jerry, like
Jerry as the Eeyore
of the group.
We do have to remind
ourselves.
And I'll send him random
texts, that I'm
just like, hey Jim.
It's Nick.
I just want to tell you
I really love you.
I think you're great.
Because otherwise, it's so
delicious and it so naughty
that we start--
There's a story coming up.
It's hardly a spoiler
to say some bad
things happen to Jerry.
Jerry gets some bad news.
And we played this gag on him.
Like, the producers and
everybody, we all just started
pretending that he was being
killed off the show.
And we started sending him
messages of like, hey Jim.
I have to tell you, I've
loved working with you.
I really think we
had a great run.
I hope you'll come back and
visit us next year.
And then we're like, OK, you
guys, we can't be mean to Jim
like he's Jerry.
He takes it all in stride and we
all have a lot of fun, but
we do have to be careful.
Because he's the sweetest--
he's an amazing wonderful nice
guy, which, that engenders
that sense of humor.
I mean, when I meet people and
they're incredibly nice and
soft-spoken and shy, it makes
me immediately want to be
shitty to them, in
a funny way.
And I let them know that it's my
way of saying I like them.
But I'm like, hey,
keep it down.
Would you shut up please?
You're disrupting the room--
to the shy, retiring person.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NICK OFFERMAN: You bet.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I recently bought tickets to
Sasquatch and noticed that you
were on the bill for that, and
was curious how you prepare
for an audience or a setting
like that, or if you've ever
done any big festival-ish
kind of shows before.
NICK OFFERMAN: I've done my
show in a couple comedy
festivals in Austin last
year, and in Chicago.
But they were still just
me in a theater.
And so it was no different,
really, other than maybe a
slightly more drunk audience
than usual.
I'm a little curious myself,
because a couple friends of
mine are also doing it
that are stand-ups.
And they said that I'm going
to be in a comedy tent.
And I'm just envisioning--
I'm very excited to
see the Gorge.
It's supposed to be the most
beautiful outdoor music venue
in Washington.
Is it in--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's outside Seattle, like
an hour and a half east.
NICK OFFERMAN: Yeah.
It's over the mountains.
AUDIENCE: Right.
NICK OFFERMAN: And I'm a little
nervous about being in
an outdoor comedy tent.
I'm envisioning hearing Cypress
Hill playing a couple
hundred yards away.
And my show is kind
of thoughtful.
It's funny, but it's like, OK,
we're going to talk about some
serious shit.
And I think I depend
on silence.
So I'm going to be putting some
thought into upping the
energy, like, what's
up, everybody?
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: So your guess
is as good as mine.
I heard from some people--
is it true that you can only
buy the whole pass to that
thing, and it's like $400?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
They used to sell single day
back a while ago, but now you
have to buy a four-day pass.
NICK OFFERMAN: That's
terrible.
AUDIENCE: That's how
all the festivals
are going these days.
NICK OFFERMAN: I'm new
to the whole thing.
I mean, I went to Lollapalooza
in '96, I think.
It was fucking awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: Chili Peppers
were the big headliner.
AUDIENCE: Do you plan on being
there for the whole weekend
and seeing some acts,
or are you just
going to do your show?
NICK OFFERMAN: I just wanted one
day-- oh, for Sasquatch?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Are you just going to
be there for your--
NICK OFFERMAN: My wife
and I are doing
a play in Los Angeles.
We had booked Sasquatch
before then.
So we're keeping the booking,
but it's the kind of thing
where we're going to have to fly
in and do the day and then
leave, unfortunately.
So we will do peyote
while we're there.
AUDIENCE: That's encouraged.
NICK OFFERMAN: I'd like to do
the full three day, the whole
vision quest.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: Maybe
next year.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
we've got time
for two more questions.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, how
does your Midwest background
influence your time on
"Parks and Rec"?
Was that the dream casting for
you, or do you throw some
Midwest-isms in there?
NICK OFFERMAN: Interestingly,
I think it has a profound
influence that is subliminal.
It's not something that
I'm cognitive of.
It's what got me the
part, probably.
It's funny, though.
When I read the script and they
started talking to me
about the role, I showed up in
jeans and a flannel shirt.
And I had pictured a guy-- they
were like, this guy runs
the parks department.
I was like, fantastic.
I drive a dark green pickup
truck and I wear work boots
and I use a shovel.
And they're like, oh,
no it's a city.
It's a small city.
So you wear shitty clothes from
JC Penney, and you work
at City Hall.
And I was like oh, wow.
OK.
I guess I'll be cool
with that.
So I think just by using my
natural Illinois demeanor, it
seems to be working
out effectively.
But I don't really--
I mean, we talk about things.
I pitched the scouting
episode were Leslie
and I each had scouts.
And the basketball team with
the pyramid of greatness,
those both came from
me saying--
and it literally is this simple,
where I'm like, can I
please have a troop of scouts?
I take things from my youth
that I think it
could provide comedy.
Or, can I please coach
a group of boys in
basketball or baseball?
And then the writers take it,
and they always extrapolate my
simple idea into something
much more complex and
delicious that I could--
they always put a twist on it,
where I'm like, of course,
I'll be badass and I'll cook
steaks over a fire.
And they're like, no, you'll
suck, and Leslie will have--
they always come up with a much
better twist on whatever
my initial thing is.
But beyond that, I keep saying
there's a ridiculous--
the show is ridiculously
bereft of fishing.
There needs to be a hell of a
lot more fishing on the show.
But LA doesn't have a lot of
great fishing locations that
can pass for Indiana.
So hopefully we'll remedy
that in the near future.
MALE SPEAKER: So they do turn
to you for kind of a Midwest
gut check sometimes?
NICK OFFERMAN: Some, but one of
our main producers, Morgan
Sackett, is from Iowa.
There's enough of a Midwestern
sensibility.
It's not cloaked information.
People have a pretty good
idea of what's going on.
But they will say--
things come up, like do you
guys say soda or pop?
Or just stuff like that, and
you find that that's
incredibly regional anyway.
People from Muncie will complain
if you say it like
people from Indianapolis.
You're screwed no matter
what you do.
AUDIENCE: So we've got a bottle
of Lagavulin here.
Can we interest you
in a drink?
NICK OFFERMAN: Christ
almighty.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: I will not allow
this occasion to go by
without imbibing, but I'll make
it a small drink, because
I have to keep my wits
about me for
3,000 people this evening.
By all means.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Actually,
on that note--
NICK OFFERMAN: I see three
glasses, and I see a great
many people.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, the
keg's in the back.
We also have some parting
gifts that--
NICK OFFERMAN: Goddamn.
Google's all right.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: You guys
should stick around.
I think you're going places.
MALE SPEAKER: We hope it can
inspire you if you have any
downtime and need to--
NICK OFFERMAN: That could
have been really ugly.
MALE SPEAKER: This is
a wooden carved
Android, and one for Megan.
NICK OFFERMAN: Thank
you so much.
She's going to love that.
And I love it too.
I love cute things.
Thank you.
That's a beautiful amount.
When I showed up, the first
time Ron had scotch on the
show, there was a bottle of
Lagavulin sitting on my desk.
And I said, these people are
so goddamn good, they found
out what my favorite
scotch is.
Because it was a little
more obscure four and
a half years ago.
And a year later at Mike
Schur's birthday party,
somebody brought him
a bottle of it.
And I said, oh, great gift.
Ron's drinking Lagavulin
because
that's my favorite scotch.
And he said, no, you idiot.
That's his favorite
scotch because
it's my favorite scotch.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: Which was
a delicious piece of
serendipity.
To comedy.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Once again, on
behalf of Google and the San
Francisco office, thanks
so much for coming by.
It's my absolute pleasure.
Thank you so much
for having me.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: Let's talk about
some other shit now.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK OFFERMAN: Thanks
very much, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]